the forces of nature remain the one
thing the man cannot control despite the
comfort our newfound capabilities to
predict inclement weather have afforded
us we are reminded time and again that
there are forces at work beyond our
understanding and as the clouds gather
we cannot always predict what will
tumble out of them this October on
Friday the 13th from an executive
producer of The Walking Dead and an
executive producer of the x-files from
six terrifying tales based on the
podcast phenomenon lore until then we
offer you this short film inspired by
the series my name is rosemary Sanders I
am an earth science teacher so that
means I know a thing or two about the
weather
having animals fall from the sky has
been documented on paper going back to
the 9th century it is disconcerting but
some people take it catastrophic aliy
new meaning was given to the phrase
raining cats and dogs in June of 2009
when scattered showers of frogs rained
down upon the residents of our cook
chief alpha and homeward as stunned
onlookers grasped for an explanation
the downpour ceased just as abruptly as
it had begun
sometimes the frogs have come down alive
as they get turned in the cloud and
broken apart sometimes its pieces of
frogs and sometimes they're frozen they
were pulled very high into this
cumulonimbus cloud it's very cold at the
top of the cloud and they will freeze
and drop suddenly
in the heat of the summer you're more
prone to have this cumulonimbus cloud
developing a waterspout and touchdown
over a pond because frogs are very
lightweight animals they can be pulled
into the cloud itself the same year a
rainfall of hundreds of fish bombarded
residents of Lajamanu Australia 326
miles from the nearest river even today
the scientific community has yet to
reach consensus on an explanation for
the phenomenon honestly it would depend
on the size of the animal it also
depends on the strength of the system
itself and it can fall great distance
from where it was first picked up
because the cloud would be traveling
when you see in reports in the Midwest
you can get softball sized hail stones
they weigh a lot more than a frog now a
lot of times
frogs are fish raining from the sky is
often seen as a sign from God or an
upset of the natural world the Old
Testament is filled with such examples
of a vengeful God's wrath in the book of
Exodus a plague of frogs rained down
upon the people of Egypt as punishment
for Pharaoh's refusal to free the
Israelites are the reigning animals an
environmental disruption to be explained
by further scientific study or these
modern-day plagues a warning that the
end of days is near it can be frogs it
can be fish and it can be Birds and any
anomaly in the natural world can be very
disruptive without sounding trite I
would say watch your step
you
[Music]